this film highlights a fortune 500
company and his dirty dealings under the
table I've always found it odd how
people say these companies are too big
to fail but when it comes to comic book
movies they never complete their evil
plan and basically fail all the time now
for one of the board members of this
organization there's this business guy
dude business guy dude used to work with
the main character's father before he
tragically had an accident later
revealed to be a horrible homicide we
hid this information at the beginning
where the bad guys making a speech
surprisingly the crowd cheers and no
one's aware of its extracurricular
activities look if you get to know me
I'm a pretty nice guy I mean I got
values and stuff see I don't always
judge people but when I do I prefer to
look at your computer first and view
your browser history with that being
said it's pretty obvious this dude is up
to no good the main character doesn't
notice anything suspicious though and in
fact the main guy gives up all the
top-secret information that the bad guy
needs in order to complete his evil plan
immediately after the podium speech part
the CEO of the evil company is
approached by this hot reporter hey lady
you drop something wet your self-respect
you don't go throwing those body parts
around like that and expect to keep it
and the CEO spends a majority of the
interview staring at her no no spots
made her find out that the bad
businessman isn't working alone there's
these people from out of town who want
to kill the hero side no I don't know
where this trend started but the
continent of Asia gets a bad rep in a
majority of these cinematic universes
apparently everybody from that continent
is a terrorist thief or killer my sons
dennis is from there and the only thing
that guy kills is germs but I'm bummed
Shh not for our hero's superhero origin
begins when a scientist may he rest in
peace does this procedure that arguably
saves the hero heroes lives it also
prevents Paramount Pictures from any
future over Jaffee's as this event will
spin off at least two more sequels after
that these dudes kidnapped the guy with
the most lines in the film as a viewer
you never really believe that there's
any real danger especially if you've
seen two Dark Knight Rises
you never blindfold someone you later
intend to kill I mean who's he or she
gonna reveal your secret hideout to then
biggie smalls I'm so sorry too soon I
don't fanboy out for armor weapons or
explosions what I'm more impressed by is
how these guys managed to get a
respectable Wi-Fi signals so deep
underground
that's it I'm switching to Verizon to
morrow after finding out something
weirds going on there's really no one
the main character to go to at this
point he or she tries to warn a room for
the
reporters but they laugh and this black
guy costs him or her crazy those be
fighting words in the Cinematic Universe
and the main guy makes a face like he or
she is about 14 seconds away from using
the n-word well somebody has to do
something so the rat one destroys his
own property and then suits up to get
his vigilante on he heads up to the
mountains to fight some vehicles and
when he arrives for the first time ever
in movie history the bad guys have
perfect aim but it still sucks because
the hero is bulletproof come to the bad
guys master plan so the bad guys are
like give me some of your insights and
the good guys are all like no no please
don't but there's nothing they could
really do because the bad guy slips I'm
a futuristic date rape weapon that
paralyzes them so they have to go with
it or whatever it worries as later on in
the garage they're able to get a 5-hour
energy like boost and get a majority of
their strength back it might be too late
though is the bad guy heads back to the
headquarter building with his metal suit
but it's so obvious we're about to get
this epic showdown between good and evil
I cannot freakin wait so the chick
breaks into the R&D department right
wait why is she even here is this one of
those it is one of those movies where
the director blew through a CGI budget
in the second act so now we have to
spend the rest of the money on this
battle that takes place on the roof then
the villain starts monologuing while the
hero is hanging on by a thread for their
dear lives and patiently wait for the
secondary human character to use a far
less expensive technique to destroy the
villain and save the day right before
the bad guy plunges to his doom but you
know why I can't even hate on her or the
writing staff for having her save the
day you can't expect to hero to eat
pizza all day and still muster enough
energy to get the job done by himself at
the end of a movie when it's all over
despite all the mixed signals the chick
was sending that one guy who flirts with
her and she rudely gives him the cold
shoulder well see if he's that nice when
it comes to saving her life
next time the sequels come around those
are 24 reasons these movies are the same
you agree Yes No maybe so that's
couch tomato Leo and his team grabs
their shelves and raise hell in next
week's adventure in a man as we've never
seen before
except you totally have the recycle plot
points are hard to limit a 24 reasons so
we found more well this guy continued to
pile up unexcused absences for leg day
any of the african-american characters
be invited back for the sequel and is
anybody really sure that these things
are loaded find out this and more on the
new episode of couch tomato PS just
click the ebony fellow with the question
mark for part 2 of the ninja saga